Well, especially when there was bad weather
or foul weather ... we didn't have an indoor
court to go to.
So we would take our basketball and go up
to the gym.
Is that the Armory?
Yeah, we used to go in there and they'd chase
us around, the police.
And then we found the Walker Auditorium, Walker
Gym where not many people went to.
So we'd go up there and play basketball.
My first connection with MIT was probably
when I was about six or seven years old, when
we were wandering and they'd put down granite
floors in the building.
And we'd be, like, belly-surfing on the floors.
Sliding on the floors that go into the revolving
door.
Or just running around there know that we're
not supposed to be out of our neighborhood.
We'd be up in Walker Memorial in the gym when
it was cold and we couldn't go to other facilities,
and we'd be playing basketball.
And we weren't a group of kids that got in
trouble at MIT.
We were a group of kids that when the MIT
police officers would come and say "Guys,
I've got to shut it down.
You have to leave, you know you're not supposed
to be here," we would leave.
But we would roam.
Now we're moving on to what is called Chocolate
City, which is a minority dormitory.
You have The Ghetto, the radio station.
So now you're talking about the 70s, and going
into '74, '75 where out of high school we're
still going to the parties, we're listening
to The Ghetto, we're going over to the Coop,
sitting up there in the cafeteria up there
now.
And we fit in.